un match à enjeu à conflans sainte
honorine ce dimanche 7 février le club
local le caj volley-ball recevait
charenton dans le championnat élite
les joueurs de michel hunault ont
largement dominé la partie dans le
premier set les bleus l'emportent 25 à
20 il ne faudra pas de détails dans les
deux sets suivants 25 à 15 et 25 à 18
score final 3 sets à 0 je pense qu on
était peut-être un petit peu mieux
préparés puis ils ont joué ils ont joué
aussi
hier soir un match en retard vous savez
avec les problèmes de kobe dont on
essaye de calais un peu les matches en
retard un peu comme on peut donc je
pense qu'ils étaient aussi très émoussé
nous entre guillemets c'était pas notre
problème il fallait qu'on fasse notre
match qu'on soit concentré sur ce qu'on
avait à faire et on l'a très bien fait
ce déplacement le club de conflans
andrésy jouy remonte dans le top 5 du
championnat élite à sept points du
podium
l'équipe affiche un bilan de quatre
matchs gagnés et 5 perdu un peu grâce à
cette victoire maintenant comme je
disais on va pouvoir vraiment regardé en
haut et arrêter de regarder en bas du
classement
donc pour nous c'est un peu une bouffée
d'air et c'est aussi porteur d'un très
bon espoir pour la suite
nos objectifs et jouer le haut de
tableau voilà c'était ça en début de
saison on n'a pas très bien géré la
situation sanitaire et qui après comme
je voulais dit de perdre des matches ça
fait qu' on est un petit peu en
difficulté on doute donc il a fallu
relancer les joueurs et donc on essaie
d'être dans les trois quatre premiers ce
qui est un petit peu plus
ouais enfin conforme à notre volonté
pourraient bien prochain match pour le
caj vbci samedi 13 février à 19h les
yvelinois se déplaceront sur le terrain
deux armes pour le compte de la 14e
journée du championnat